et puis on pourrait dire quand même deux
mots alors de zola photographier qu'il
n'a pas de talent de photographe nos
relances intéresse c'est un livre
admirable et que tout le monde doit
avoir pour deux raisons d'abord c'est
des photos de zola et c'est un document
extraordinaire sur joe l'arc est quand
même un peu nos minimes ans et puis ce
sont des photos de 1900 est actuellement
toute photo de datant de près d'un
siècle est quand même extrêmement
intéressante quant à savoir si c'est un
photo ap je ne crois pas justement parce
qu'il n'est pas de créateurs alors la
photo pour zola ont dit les photos de
cela on s'imagine qu'on va voir le
dossier de la bête humaine le dossier de
germinal
non ça il a rien fait de ce genre
c'était tout autre chose je crois que il
avait des portraits de famille voilà la
photo pour cela correspondait à 2
frustration d'abord il a fait ses études
à aix avec cézanne il voulait être
peintre et sézanne voulait est romancier
au début comme un poète et puis les
vocations se sont croisés il ya toujours
eu je crois un peintre rentrer chez eux
et quand ils gagnent appareil de photo
il a fait de la peinture alors des
portraits des paysages des autoportraits
et des autocollants
je vous recommande par exemple les
autoportraits des pages 160 à 175
il ya aussi chez lui une seconde
frustration qui est la frustration
familiale savait qu'il avait une femme
qui ne pouvait pas avoir d'enfant
alexandrine et il a eu des enfants avec
la lingère de sa femme la jeune jeanne
rosereau il a eu deux enfants jacques et
denise et il ne pouvait pas les voir
normalement c'était une famille d'une
terrine à l'époque c'est extrêmement
grave et je crois que cette vie de
famille qui ne pouvaient pas avoir parce
que c'était une famille et régulière eh
bien il a compensé en grande partie en
photographiant sa femme et ses enfants
saint jeanne rose au jacques et denise
et c'est adorable c'est adorable parce
que c'est vraiment le père de famille
qui adore ses enfants et qui les
photographient avec bonheur c'est un
très beau livre